I have already posted on YouTube
the full agreement of the PSOE Yun.
You have the link in the description of my biography.
Yuns considers legitimate
the result and mandate of the October 1 referendum,
as well as its proclamation of independence.
27/10/2017 1 real madness because PSOE and Yun
They have shaken hands and signed their pact today.
of Face to the investiture of Pedro.
After days of negotiations,
the thing
has been recorded and just a few minutes ago
which is a holiday.
In Madrid
They have announced the agreement to invest Pedro,
but be careful,
because it has a small print,
that no one says so and they disagree
and it doesn't come out anywhere.
Please share it.
I make spoilers for you and you have it more developed.
on YouTube.
Puigdemont's accusation for terro isthmus,
not to ban it,
makes him the only separatist
whom he may not pardon or give amnesty
Pedro Sanchez
in accordance with article 83.1
of the founding treaty of the European Union.
YouTube summary in 1 line
the 34-page magistrate's order that I have read
you have already published it there